now speaking of the hearings one must
feel a certain amount of
sympathy for the democrats who have been
put in the unenviable position of having
to invent some reason to oppose the
confirmation of a universally respected
admired
well-qualified female supreme court
justice presumably they've already
skimmed through her high school yearbook
found no ammunition there probably
decided to be too
difficult uh you know to make outlandish
sexual assault
allegations stick to a woman especially
and particularly when they didn't even
stick to brett kavanaugh
so their options here are very limited
um and as the senate confirmation
hearings unfold this week
democrats and their allies in the media
have tried a number of different tax
you know they've they've looked at a few
different ways they can go about this
and with with no success at all having
realized that their
ginsburg's dying wish gambit also wasn't
landing because there is no dying wish
clause in the constitution as it turns
out
they've rallied around the almost as
absurd notion that republicans would be
guilty of court packing should they
exercise their constitutional power to
confirm a supreme court nominee like we
talked about yesterday senator dick
durbin
lamented that republicans have quote
taken every vacancy and filled it
pretending not to know
that court packing is not when vacancies
are filled but when they are created
by adding seats what else are
republicans supposed to do with a
vacancy but fill it
saving a few for the democrats might be
good sportsmanship but that hardly
qualifies as a constitutional
obligation nor as a persuasive argument
during opening statements on monday
senator cory booker
claimed that the hearing was
illegitimate because
as he eloquently put it listen the
american people should decide
the american people should decide the
american
people should decide i will not be
voting to confirm
judge barrett's nomination very dramatic
stuff there from corey very affecting i
felt that
senator amy klobuchar for her part
tweeting during the hearing when she
really should have been paying attention
i think
posted this isn't donald trump's country
it's yours
this shouldn't be donald trump's judge
it should be yours
but what these appeals to democracy
ignore is that the electorate
gave control of the senate to
republicans and elected donald trump to
a four-year term
their mandate from the voters like their
constitutional power doesn't expire a
month before the next election
the american people did decide or to put
it in terms
cory booker might be able to understand
the american people did decide the
american people did decide the american
people
did decide democrats in the hearing
have repeatedly tried to make hay out of
the fact that we're in the middle of a
pandemic
so we've heard a lot about that on
monday senator maisie hirono spent her
opening statement recounting the horrors
of the chronovirus
and its effects on the economy or rather
the effects of the lockdown on the
economy
but she could never quite explain why
the coronavirus should prevent a supreme
court justice from being confirmed
especially when it didn't prevent
hundreds of black lives matter rallies
all across the country for three months
in a row
booker sputtered something about how
it's not
normal this isn't normal to have
confirmation hearings
during a pandemic it isn't normal now
the obvious
response to that claim is so what
pandemics themselves aren't normal
therefore the things we do during them
won't be normal but that doesn't mean we
should stop doing
as much as that has actually been the
strategy of course for the last six
months
not a good one and speaking of normal it
wasn't normal to attempt to block a
supreme court nominee by accusing him of
being a serial gang rapist
democrats seem to aspire to normalcy
only under very limited circumstances
and of course some of the criticisms of
barrett have taken a more personal tone
much has been made of the fact that she
served as a handmaid in a group called
people of praise
but the protesters dressed in ridiculous
red costumes outside the hearing seemed
not to know that
handmade in barrett's case was a
reference to the bible
not a book written by margaret atwood in
the 1980s
and this sort of confusion is inevitable
when your exposure to historical
literature extends only to that novel
plus harry potter and twilight
now predictably the fact that barrett
has seven children has also been the
subject of attack
many examples here here's just one
author lauren hoff
mocked the judge for her quote clown car
vagina
many of the twitter followers laughed
and applauded one of them commented that
delivering a child is like quote taking
a dump
now i'm tempted to say that many of
barrett's critics are jealous that she's
an attractive and successful woman
with a husband and children while they
have only their cats and netflix
accounts to keep them company
as they slowly shrivel away into
nothingness to be forgotten by everyone
and mourned by no one
but i'm not going to say that because it
would be uncharitable i won't say that
someone might say that but i'm not going
to anyway the interesting thing is that
this narrative of amy coney barrett the
barefoot baby factory
handmade submissive is being advanced
alongside the claim
that as slate argued this week she is a
ruthless self-promoting careerist
who's concerned only with her own
professional advancement
now of course god forbid anyone were to
utter such slander about say
senator camilla harris who began her
political career in bed with a
well-connected and still married we
might add
california politician it'd be
horrifically sexist to make that sort of
charge against
the democratic vice presidential
candidate but bear it for obvious
reasons
for obvious political reasons is fair
game
these are all the desperate cries of
people
who cannot utter their real objection
except in euphemism
harris joining the hearing remotely
declared that barrett would undo
ginsburg's legacy by the way there is no
clause in the
constitution requiring that a deceased
justice's legacy be respected
or upheld either and she also said that
barrett would roll back
americans rights what she means here
what everyone's cited above really means
is that
justice amy coney barrett might make it
harder for parents to legally kill their
children
this is the real source of all of the
impotent rage being directed at the
nomination the hearings and barrett
personally
if she believed in a mother's right to
kill her offspring none of the people
mentioned here
would be objecting on the contrary they
would extol her brilliance and beauty
and bravery
and their venom would be reserved for
the people doing what they themselves
are doing right now
democrats have no problem with this
flagrant hypocrisy because
they believe themselves to be opposing
literally hitler
the other side of the aisle to them
represents
abject evil racism bigotry the
enslavement of women
those in their camp who don't believe
this at least want everyone to believe
they believe it
but meanwhile it doesn't require
exaggeration or hysteria or recourse to
dystopian fantasy novels to believe
rather to notice to know that they are
the ones who actually do
support fund and facilitate one of the
most hideous forms of evil the world has
ever seen
60 million human beings have been
butchered since and because of
the supreme court decision that these
people hail as the high water mark of
the civil rights movement
many of these humans have been killed in
the very early stages of pregnancy a
fact that makes their murder no less
evil
but many millions have been executed at
a stage late enough
to require dismemberment before the
corpses can be extracted from the womb
this mass grave this mountain of corpses
this
systematic extermination of our own
children is what cory booker camila
harris joe biden
all the rest of them are so jealously
and vengefully guarding
they pretend to be fighting evil and
they've given themselves the moral
license to lie and cheat to that end
but they are in fact the genocidal
fascists
they pretend to oppose and we should
always keep that in mind when we watch
the hearings
this week well hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content